[موسيقى]
لكن ايضا دعم العقوبات مهم للغايه بالنسبه
الى اوكرانيا وبالطبع نجري حوارا مثمرا
للغايه مع شركائنا من الاتحاد الاوروبي
والولايات المتحده والدول الشركه الاخرى
التي تنضم بشان زياده ضغط العقوبات على
روسيا كما نعلم ان اوروبا تبنت بالفعل
احدى عشره حزمه من العقوبات ونطلب من
شركائنا فرض عقوبات على الصناعه النوويه
الروسيه وعلى صناعه تعدين الماس وايضا
عقوبات شخصيه وفرديه على السياسيين الروس
ومديريه تلك الشركات المتعلقه بتمويل
الحرب في اوكرانيا لماذا تعد العقوبات
مهمه من المهم جدا التاكيد ان العقوبات لا
تمنح روسيا فرصه لملء الميزانيه التي تمول
من خلالها العدوان المسلح هذه الحرب
الدمويه في الواقع حرب ارهابيه
واباده جماعيه للشعب الاوكراني والعقوبات
ايضا لا تسمح لروسيا بالتزويد بالمعدات
التكنولوجيه الحديثه التي تسمح لهم ايضا
بانتاج الاسلحه التي يقتلون بها
الاوكرانيين
[موسيقى]
يجب القول ان قضيه فرض العقوبات لها
جانبان دائما الجانب الاول هو اضعاف قدره
المعتدي روسيا علشان مثل هذه الحرب
والجانب الاخر للعقوبات هو التقرير
تاثيرها السلبي على الدول في الحصول على
المعدات اللازمه في الصناعات العسكريه من
الدول الغربيه والبحث عن هذا الحل الوسط
هو ما يدور حوله الحوار الداخلي في الدول
الاوروبيه بين دول مجموعه السبع ومجموعه
العشرين
من المهم بالنسبه الينا ان نفهم ان
العقوبات تلعب دورها الرئيسي في الواقع
واضعاف روسيا ومنعها من انتاج وتمويل
اسلحه جديده لقتل الاوكرانيين وهذا هو
الهدف الاساسي
[موسيقى]